first of all on uh kovid's status
certification as we
as we prefer to to call it i think the
most important thing to say
to everybody listening and watching is
that uh
there is absolutely no uh question of
people being asked to produce
a certification or uh covered status
uh report when they go to the uh to the
to the shops or uh to the pub garden
uh or to the hairdressers or whatever in
uh
on monday so and indeed uh we're not
planning
uh that for step three either uh
may the 17th as you know uh we're hoping
to go for
uh the opening up of indoor hospitality
uh and and so on uh we're not planning
for anything of that kind
at that stage but i think what is
certainly true is that
the idea of um a
vaccination status being useful for
international
travel is is something that all
countries are
looking at i do think that's going to be
part of our uh of the way people deal
with it we need to think about that
but uh there are basically three
ingredients to uh your covid
certification or three ways
that you can give reassurance to uh to
others if you go to
uh to a big mass event and
uh or or ways you can
that people can be assured that the
people in the room uh
don't uh have the risk of spreading
coping the number one is your your
immunity
uh so if you had it if you had the virus
before in the last or certainly in the
last six months you'll have
uh the antibodies number two uh
obviously is is vaccination status
uh but number three is is testing and
testing really is valuable i've been
talking about this for a long time but
the nhs as you know is now offering
uh free lateral flow tests i do think
that they are
uh for for asymptomatic uh people as as
well i do think that they're
uh they're they're they're an important
part of of the way forward but
i want to stress that there are
complicated ethical and practical
issues as i think i said last time
raised by the idea of covid uh status
certification
because after for vaccination uh using
vaccination
alone just because after all many people
um will be for one reason or another uh
unable to
to get a vaccine where for medical
reasons for instance or or perhaps
because they're pregnant or
whatever so you've got to be very
careful in how you handle this and
and don't uh start a system that's
that's uh discriminatory
um but obviously we're looking at it we
want to be going ahead in the next
uh a few weeks with uh some test events
some pilot events which
which you can see in the uh in the in
the the road map that we've
uh that we've laid out and uh big events
like you know getting 20 000 people into
into wembley on on may the 15th uh that
kind of thing uh
getting people back into uh a theater
uh that will unquestionably involve uh
testing uh to to allow the the audience
uh
to really to participate in in the
numbers that that people want
as for um a a vote on the
on the issue uh well i think that's
we're taking too many fences at once
first of all we need to to
to work out exactly what the proposal uh
might be
uh but certainly if there's something to
put to parliament i
have no doubt that we'll be doing that
but i want to stress again that that is
not going to happen
in step two april 12th or step three
may the the 17th i hope that that helps